THE SUB GAP IS LESS THAN 26,000,
and I'm going on a holiday.
*dab*
[Glowing sound effect]
G O O O D D A M N I I I I I I T ! ! ! ! ! ! !
*LWIAY intro starts*
[👏] Another week[👏], another meme, everyone.
Say it with me; "new week [Felix echo: new week], new memes [Felix echo new memes]".
Let's start this year off with a- epic memesters
Let's check out what we have this time!
HA! That is BULLYING. Eh, that 6969
though, am I right? (That's a sex number).
[ laughs like a sociopath]
[Ends laughing]
Obviously, I alternate, okay? Stop being stupid! I'm not gonna wear the pants the exact same way every single day
That'd be stupid.
You may think I have a really long sweater?
N O
i don't have legs :'(
I'm hovering above- I'm hovering above as I do.
TuRurURuUrUuRuRurURue
This is how I walk
[Elevator music playing]
[Roomie] Felix is insecure about his height
and that's why he needs to be number one, because it's the ONLY thing that can really
distract him from the fact that he's not as tall as he wants to be.
[Felix] So, there's been a lot of rumors going on after this video,
with Roomie where-- he forced to measured me.
[Felix] Just in case that he doesn't show the [?]
[Roomie] Yahhh, alright.
Okay.
[Felix] 1,8- [Laughs and stops laughing]
Just want to be clear I was hovering extra low, that's why it's said 1,79. I mean 1,80.
[Roomie] I'm getting a UhHhHhHhHhHh..
[Felix, quietly] 1,85?
[Roomie] NO ho ho-
a 1,75
I'm getting.
[Explosion video playing]
L  I  E  S  ! ! ! ! ! ! !
O K A Y ? ? ?
L I  E S ! ! ! ! ! ! [Ends explosion video]
Don't-- you can never trust a Swede. Take it from a Swede. NEVER trust a Swede
[Rock starts playing and Brad 1/Sive 1 putting zoom effect]
This is lies and nothing but lies, okay?
You can't measure with your freaking thumb? What are you? Stupid?
Unsubscribed. Thank you!
[ reads meme ]
Okay 9GAG,
discrimination.
Can you imagine Shrek's penis?
I will rest my case, not the fair comparison.
I've seen this one.
[Starts laughing]
Meme in 2018 vs 2019.
I like everyone was on board with this meme,
and then Gillette ad comes out of nowhere and everyone's like "well, yeah
It's so terrible."
Like, shut t H E E F U U U U U U--
[Reversed explosion video playing]
[and then stops]
Can we get some 'F's in the chat?
Everyone clearly cared about this man so much so that they will refer to him as
"this man"
*intense song starts*
Oh my god, dammit, OUT OF ALL [👏] LETTERS [👏] IN [👏] THE ALPHABET!
There's no escape. I can't WIN. I can only LOSE!
[ reads meme ]
The mad lad survived 18 years! Epic Victory Royale #1, well done!
Minecraft Christian [👏] se[👏]rver.
We are banned from Roblox, but minecraft Christian server
[Angelic music]
I guess I got no other choice.*START PAYING TO BRAD AND YOU WILL RISE*
OH MY GOOOOOOOOOOOD! EHAEHAH!
What are the odds? That's amazing!
YouTube admits massive oopsie, but also makes a MASSIVE winsee, DAMN!
WHAT????? If I catch you--
Any of you non 9-year olds. Imma
[Puts massive frickin' bass and blurs it out to not get demonetized]*CLASSIC FELIX*
[Laughs and ends laughing.]
That's good
That's a really good meme.
HEY, I never thought of that, what an öptimistic viewpöint, I appreciate it, thank you.
*reads name of the account*
Well, now it's ruined, you ruined the meme. Congratulations.
[ends saying 'news' and starts laughing]
Gloria. Borger.
[Epic Pew News Intro]
Goddamnit, where did you answer this, like, where is this from?
What kind of questionnaire is this?
Awh. (•◡•)
It's chibi PewDiePie and Mr. Beast with slightly homosexual undertones.
I LIKE IT!!
I like the bed sheets though. That's really cool! I love the style.
That's all I will ever ask.
Please just be here when they pass [the sub-gap]
WHICH THEY NEVER [WILL], ALRIGHT???????
I'm going on a holiday because I feel so confident
TeTetteetTEteTE.
Because I feel so confident in my abilities that we will crush them
THAT'S WHY!!! T-Series, bring it!!!!
Oh God, did I kill Fortnite?
Yeah, was it literally the same day? That's so funny. Sorry Fortnite! You know I had to do with to ya.
I've done it to roblox and I will do it to any other game, you want pyramids?
It bothers me that is doesn't even pointing correctly.
AND THAT IS A FACT!!!!!!!!!
There you go kids. You got a new improved version.
"Big oof", you might say, but a big Victory Royale #1 I WILL say,
I was super surprised and very
Happy to see that Susan actually commented on my video, and left really nice constructive
uHuhUhUhUhU
Comments about it about the demonization question. I think that's so cool!
I'm really glad that she's engaging with the community and actually responding to things,
I didn't necessarily directly ASK her!
Damn! I should put that on the um...
I should put that on the thing. That looks sick. That would be really good
Um... I don't know if it looks good on this camera though.
Thank you
I like it.
Can we get some 'F's in the CHAT?*FFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFF*
AHHHhHhHhhHh,
My favorite movie of franchise of all time. No
aHahHahAhAhAh
I'm just kidding.
I feel bad, raccoons are awesome animals, and I would love to have one as a pet one day,
although I probably shouldn't.
Moving on!
It was five days ago. Your dumb balls!
GrAgAGagagaga
You will not stop you! Screw you, you taxols!
Screw you!
Stop [👏] making [👏] fun [👏] of my camera
What camera did you steal from me, Brad? He had so much better quality!
Even the mic!
If everything was BETTER, I'm sitting it-- with the sub tear equipment!
(Except this chair, by the way,) this is an excellent Italian leather chair
I think that has Kevlar inside as well.
[👏]
Oh my god
I'm gonna miss all the Aladdin memes, now that I'm away. Gosh darn it
Hehe!
I've already talked about this many times and memes were created by aliens
okay?
You may think I'm crazy.
They were created by aliens to halt the progression of mankind
So that aliens living millions of years to-- away from us, by the time they arrived with the full innovation
We will have not progress whatsoever, and we'll still be laughing at dumbass Shrek memes.
Haha!
I hope that answers your question and good luck on your speech in class
It's the worst meme I've ever seen in my life, goddamnit!
Yeah, it's working out really well so far. I'm not scared at all
like honestly easy
easy peasy t-series
OUR ONLY HOPE!
Youtube, I am completely against deleting channels, but youtube with it
Just this one favor youtube (plz)
i work so hard i need a vacation guys
Listen, I'm whispering. Alright, so T series can't hear it'sa...it's a..it's a...trap t series. Well swoop in thinking
Oh, the gates are open he's away. And then oh
(grunts) Plan .X Will initiate plan X. Now
Please let plan X not be some Nazi ploy. Okay Frick *ACTUALLY IT IS*
I'm so sorry. Gomenasai/ごめんなさい (sorry) Elon-san. Gomenasai/ごめんなさい. I'll burn it I burn it
I promise.
Kicking T-Series to save PewDiePie!
An old friend joins the party!
Leg Man is back! Arigatou gozaimasu Leg Man! See this is what I'm talking about.
Everyone is doing their part. It's truly wonderful to see communities come together for a greater cause of good.
I've seen no one talk about this battle going on oh god [laughs]
Jack, oh no. Well, I guess this means I have to play fortnite with ninja to kill his channel
I'm sorry. It had to be done.
Took me three days. I hope you like it.
That's amazing!
I love how do you capture the dead look in my eyes how many people can do that? Very nice. *ASK MARZIA *
Thank you very much. Vice did an oopsie. Women talk about the worst body shaming they've ever experienced.
Finally a new emoji to mock men's penis sizes! Yay!
The 180 that VICE just did I don't know where it's so so perfect because you could just pull out
Any old article from them and compare it to their new ones. Damn
Took me a while, but we are currently in the endgame of God, but this isn't the end
It isn't there guys. Honestly, like all trust me on this one. It's gonna be fine. It's gonna be fine
What? Oh my god is she wrapped yourself crooks?
subscribe
Got a painting of me. Oh it's a painting
Pretty good. That is pretty good. Thank you grandma for doing your part
Can we get Felix to put this on his TV? So the media can never take about a country suit today?
I'll just spit all this point of the TV and then I could say whatever I why
Dear PewDiePie. Hey, man, my name is Thomas brush
I'm the creator of pin stripe you did voice acting for pin stripe pro bono, of course, I know
Like I'll turn the favor. So I have this really cool idea of making a game
Maybe about you and t-series and I want a live stream the creationist get it done in two weeks
I dare you to dare me to make this game [Felix] I dare you to dare me to dare you!
To come up with the ideas about this game
You can post it in the subreddit or come hang out during the live streams in the live chat and come up with ideas
Live as I'm this game as long as this game is a 2d platformer
I can pretty much do anything you need me to into we like the music could do the code I can do art animation
-Design, development
dAmN !
You name it.
-You name it I think it'd be really cool for you and your audience to throw amazing ideas at me and see this game come to life
I think it's a really cool idea
I'd love to see you win the battle against t-series and if we can do that in a video game
I think it'd be awesome. This is the last play. All right, check out Atmos games leave your suggestions
Let's freakin do this. That's it from me this week of LWIAY, now
I am going away but I still have videos prepared. That's right t-series. That's right. You thought you could beat me ha
got videos prepared bitch
Suck my f*ckin Swedish meatballs! Thank you guys so much for all the love and support and most importantly
Of course
THE MEMES! See you broskis on the hoskis.
You want pyramids? We got em!
Oh you're into castles huh? wE gOt yOu cOveReD bAbY !! You want some pets? EASY!
We. Got it. ALL.
This game is still relevant goddammit!